you have to expect to suck at the  beginning just expect to suck  whenever you're starting something from  the beginning you're starting a new  business idea you're starting a youtube  channel you're launching a podcast  whatever it is  expect to suck most people  never start because you expect to be  great and that's the problem  that is keeping you where you are your  addiction to perfection  is the disease that we need to solve to  cure  to help you get to where you want to go  and what you know you're capable of  doing  so in my movie makers program we just  started a 100 video challenge  100 video challenge you got to make 100  videos because i think people quit  way too soon i showed people in my group  where  i was at 100 videos and i had a couple  hundred views i had three comments  on my 100th video 100 videos in then i  showed garyvee's 100th video and he had  800 views or something and also three  comments and i think we just judge  ourselves  too harshly too soon